Film Courage: Are you able to tell us how
you found financing for DANGER ONE?
Tom Oesch, Filmmaker: It was pretty straightforward.
Once we had the sizzle done…let me rewind.
When Stephen the writer and I started working
on the script and the sizzle, I had lunch
with a producer friend of mine and I just
briefly gave him the log line and he’s like
“Oh my gosh!
That’s awesome.
When you’re done, let me see it.”
We’re good friends and go back a few years.
Also someone I met through a friend that I
went to school with obviously.
But when we were all done my managers sent
it out to people and a few companies and I
sent it to my producer friend and he loved
it.
How did that go?
Because he had produced the pyramid for FOX.
So he was in Lebanon at the time that I sent
him the stuff because it was the Middle Eastern
premiere of the PYRAMID.
And at the same time he was there another
movie called POCKET LISTING also premiered
in Lebanon.
That one was produced by the people who ended
up financing DANGER ONE.
And so Chatty (my producer friend) was in
Lebanon at the time he was set to go to the
premiere of POCKET LISTING.
And at time he met the financiers and they
had just finished a movie and they were looking
for something new and I told them what they
were looking for and Chatty was like “Oh
my gosh.
You should check this out.
I’ve got a sizzle and a script.”
At that point things moved pretty fast.
We probably spent two months rewriting the
script and five months later we were on set.
Film Courage: So you put your own money in
for the sizzle reel and in the end you got
someone to finance the film.
Tom: Yes I wouldn’t be able to finance the
film.
On an editor’s salary I would be able to
finance a film this size.
Our budget wasn’t high especially for a
movie this ambitious and it was a full union
shoot but we got it done.
Film Courage: You think because it was mostly
interior or in that one warehouse or whatever
with the ambulance that this saved so much
money?
Tom: Oh yes.
I mean honestly I don’t know how we got
this done with the time we had and the budget,
it’s a bit of a miracle.
And in hindsight I do think it would be good
if we had (and I know every director will
tell you that) a little bit more.
But we still had a whole lot of locations
(we had to cover 23 days) so for us to be
able to spend the first two weeks of those
23 days in that warehouse basically covering
everything that happens in the warehouse and
also inside the ambulance was the only way
to get that done.
The last two weeks that’s when we headed
out but we still had so many locations where
you have a company move in the middle of the
day doing one scene here and then everyone
gets in their cars and their trucks and you
travel somewhere else.
But a lot of the scenes we sort of shot around
that warehouse.
The funny thing is there is a scene in the
movie where they are getting rid of the firefighter’s
in the manhole and we were looking for a location
for that.
So when we were in the warehouse.
We used it as a sound stage and it should
not be used as a sound stage.
Sound stages are sound proof, that’s what
makes them a sound stage.
This was actually an old warehouse but what’s
worse is literally right next to that warehouse
was a recycling plant.
So we’re shooting inside this warehouse
and all night long/all day long you’ve got
these trucks pushing containers with metal
cans and bottles against our wall which was
why a lot of the sound was unusable and we
had to ADR a lot of it.
But we were like “Can we take a look at
this recycling plant?
Maybe we can shoot there?”
And we eventually ended up shooting a whole
scene in there literally just next door.
Film Courage: So when you found out that most
of the sound wasn’t usable how shocking
was this?
Maybe you knew that was coming?
Tom: Well we knew it was coming because we
heard it on set.
This was not a good situation to be in, especially
on a low-budget film you don’t want to have
to ADR half your movie.
A lot of the stuff that happened in there
we had to ADR in post.
We had a long ADR schedule on this movie.
Film Courage: How long did that set you back?
Because you probably had an idea that it was
going to be released by a certain time.
Tom: Just because certain things didn’t
go according to planned during the production
(this happens on movies a lot), the post production
budget kind of moved into production.
So when you get to post production you have
to be really smart.
Things will just take longer because there
now is less money to get it done than there
was before.
So our post…how long was that?
Because we shot in 2016 in March and April
and I were we in post for like a year…probably?
Because also actors are out of town shooting
things and you have to start scheduling around
their availability.
The further removed from principal photography
the harder it gets.
We finished toward the fall of 2017, so yes
post was a year.
Film Courage: Did you have all the actors
come back for ADR?
All the major players?
Tom: I think so?
Tom Everrett Scott was in for like 4 days.
Yes Dennis O’Hare we had to come in from
New York.
We even had some ADR done in Lebanon because
the actor was in Lebanon.
So we had to visit a studio there and do a
Skype call.
So yes, pretty much all the major players
were in for a day (half a day) and some of
the smaller ones.
Film Courage: How does this work?
So you’ve gone through the entire movie
and you know from this time mark to this the
sound is horrible and this line needs to be
redone.
So you’re charting all of this?
Tom: I wasn’t but the post sound department
they were.
And that was the first time I’d done this.
They basically just gave me a long list of
here’s the time code, here’s the line,
get the line.
The good thing about this is it actually allows
you to tweak the performance.
I know a lot of actors don’t like ADR and
I get it because you’re in a booth and it
doesn’t feel…you know being on set there
is the environment and the other actor is
in front of you and you can really get into
it, you’re having an actual interaction.
It allows you to get out of your head and
really just be in that moment.
ADR you are in tiny padded booth by yourself
and the acting experience becomes very artificial.
You’re just saying the line over and over
again.
Because a lot of actors hate doing it.
As a director and for the post crew it allowed
us to tweak certain performances to even out
the tone a little bit, to take certain things
down a notch.
Also to be writing certain likes that were
actually off camera because scenes might have
gotten cut.
There are a couple of scenes that may not
have even shot.
We some how had to get that content in where
ADR was the best.
So it wasn’t just replacing the crappy production
audio it was also replacing the story.
Film Courage: So how do you get that to match
the bad sound that’s in Vernon [where they
shot the film] that probably has a very distinct
feel and then you have this pristine both?
How is that working?
Tom: During the mix there is an ADR editor
so they already do some filtering on it and
then during the mix you try to make it sound
as much as possible as during production.
Sometimes they just advise you to ADR the
whole scene because they are just like we’re
never going to be able to match this.
If you know what lines are ADR you can tell.
When I watch it I’m like “there’s an
ADR right there.”
I don’t know if audiences can, but it’s
not easy.
Film Courage: So you know it because you know
there is more reverb or whatever, you can
just hear more of an echo or something and
this was too crisp but most of the time the
audience won’t know.
Tom: Well now having done it I can actually
hear it in other movies, even on like big
movies it’s like “There’s an ADR line
right there.”
Film Courage: You have an editor’s ear.
Tom: Well in reality TV, I guess we do some
of that but it’s not on this level.
ADR in reality TV is talent will say it in
their iPhone and record it and then like text
it over.
It’s not quite on the same level as on a
feature.
Film Courage: But then too with a lot of reality
TV there is music playing the entire time
under the [dialogue] so that would probably
filter a lot.
Tom: But reality TV you do quite a bit of
wild nights with dialogue cheated that people
record on their iPhones during interviews
and we make it sound like it’s actually
happening.
Like I said, not a lot of reality in reality
TV.
Film Courage: iPhone audio can sound excellent.
Tom: Well audio on reality TV is already kind
of crappy so the audio from the iPhone is
going to fit in nice (it’s not going to
stand out that much).